former president trump will visit the
border today for the first time since
leaving office
president trump will tour mcallen texas
with governor greg
abbott about 800 miles farther south
than vice president harris's visit last
week
the former president's visit comes as
immigration agents find and they rescue
look at that a two-year-old little boy
abandoned by the side of the road in
mexico
tarrant county texas sheriff bill
wayburn is joining the former president
on his trip today and he joins us now
good morning to you sheriff
good morning angela and god bless you
and thank you for having me oh god bless
you i pray that he always keeps you and
your men and women safe
tell me what your role is today you'll
be meeting with president trump
i will be and my briefing will be
specifically what is
coming across the border doesn't stay on
the border we know it goes out and one
of the major hubs unfortunately is the
dallas fort worth area where it goes
north and up
and out and it's the the drug issues and
human trafficking issues but
specifically i'll be talking about
the threat of fentanyl to to our country
how it is a clear and present threat and
since
february this year texas law enforcement
has seized enough fentanyl to kill every
man
woman and child in the state of new york
and if that isn't shocking enough we're
seeing a
50 increase in fatal overdoses
in the greater tarrant county area so
i'll be talking about that
throughout okay tell us how does that to
the average viewer at home they might
say oh well that i'm not going to see
this fentanyl but we interviewed some
parents
recently and they talked about how their
young children
really young teenagers died because they
took
one drug they thought it was one thing
and it was something else it was laced
with another drug
how serious is this it's incredibly
serious and what we're seeing is even
the low-level dealers have ample amount
of fentanyl that they're lysing heroin
they're lacing
designer drugs that the kids often use
and we're seeing this population between
the ages of 16 and 24
being a complete uh that that their that
age group right there is who we're
losing to this
and what i would say to the parents
whether they're sitting in new york or
they're sitting in california
folks please invade the space of your
children know who they're talking to
see what's going on on social media
because this looks like a safe drug
they're using pill presses
and it looks like oh this isn't any more
dangerous than marijuana or
a prescription drug and it's deadly so
scary
so scary for parents almost a 300 rise
in fentanyl seizures
this may compare to last may now kamala
harris listen to this she
is she's saying it's not their fault
they inherited this situation
as you know we inherited a tough
situation i've looked at a
system where people have been housed in
inhumane conditions over the last
many years an asylum system that has
been broken
and that needs to be reconstructed and
in five months we've made progress but
there's still much more work to be done
but we've made progress
what's your reaction to that sheriff my
reaction is very clear
on the on the streets of texas today in
january
methamphetamine another deadly drug
that's laced with fentanyl was going for
fifty dollars a gram today you can buy
it for fifteen to twenty dollars a gram
the the the incredible seizures of drugs
the things that we have
caught coming across the border and the
things that we've caught
in country up in the tarrant county and
dallas county area we're having huge
loads of drugs
that are being seized so there hasn't
been any progress the the border is open
and uh you know we're talking about the
kids coming across
and we have got a crisis on the border
we in that crisis
is growing throughout america and we can
draw a lot in the sand someplace and
take care of it we've got some heroic
border sheriffs down here doing an
incredible job with their federal
partners
and dps but it's no sheriff we really
appreciate everything you're doing thank
you so much
enjoy your day with president trump and
with the governor
god bless y'all and thank you god bless
you too thank you